There's a remote landscape in the
American Southwest that has a dark past.
Back in the 1930s,
a rancher was searching these mountains
for gold.
He described stone towers up on ridges.
He decided to search those towers to see
if by chance they contained any gold.
But they didn't.
And he found something else instead.
What he found compelled him to travel to
the nearest town and seek out experts.
Those experts were archaeologists.
Years ago, Max and I were on a hike out
here following this ridgeline and a
thunderstorm came in.
We had to hunker down from the lightning
for about an hour and after it cleared,
we continued on down the ridge
and I stumbled across this site. And I
didn't know at the time that I was
headed into a story with a very dark
past.
Now, I'm going to tell you what that is,
but first I want to try and find the
site that the rancher found because this
site isn't it.
I don't know exactly where it is. I have
a hunch of where it's at. From what I
know, these sites are supposed to be
connected through line of sight and the
obvious line of sight out here is that
nearby ridge. So, what I want to do is
spend the next 2 or 3 days out here
hiking along these ridgelines and by day
2 or 3 depending on our progress, we
should get to where I think that site
is.
And hopefully find out whether that
tower is still standing. All right, so I
got to have enough water for me and Max.
That with all my camera gear and my
drone.
Oh, yeah.
I got to get this.
So, I'm going to spend two nights out
here. That's 3 days hiking along the
ridge of this mountain range to see if I
could find
any more sites and especially see if I
could find an existing tower.
Trying to get to the top before sundown.
Probably
3 400 m from the top.
All right, so I made it to the top and
I'm at the far end of the ridge and I'm
just south of the north end of it. So,
I'm going to walk out there
see if by chance there's anything there.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, man, that's pretty cool. I mean,
it's unfortunate it's not a standing
tower, but reading all these
archaeological reports, understanding
that there's so many towers out here
that have line of sight with each other.
It seems like that on the tops of these
ridges, there should be towers.
Let's take a closer look.
I wonder
how deep it is inside.
All right, so it's not that deep inside.
Unfortunately,
it's no standing tower. It is the base
of what looks like a tower, probably.
But now,
we're running out of daylight, and I
need to find a flat place to camp.
So,
this spot seems pretty flat
right here.
All right, let's see how quick we can
get this done.
Tent is set up.
Max, you ready to eat some dinner?
Are you hungry?
Oh, yeah, the good stuff.
I really wanted to have a fire out here,
but
recently they enacted a fire ban with
how dry the whole western United States
has been, so sticking with my stove
tonight.
I'm going to sign off for the night, and
I'll see you in the morning.
Maxi, want to say good morning?
Max is still really wanting to
take on those coyotes.
Finish eating, get my camp broken down,
and then we'll get [snorts] moving.
Before I pack up my camp, I just wanted
to walk back up to the site and
take it in before the sun comes up.
I can't imagine what it was like to live
out here.
To live in somewhat constant fear, fear
of starving, running out of water.
The grizzlies could get you, the
mountain lions could get you.
Fear that someone might try and kill
you.
Despite all the stress in our modern
world, I feel grateful
to have the comforts of home.
>> All right, packed up and ready to go.
Today's goal is to get to the top of
that ridge there
and then follow it all the way south
miles and miles because at the far end
of it that's the original site that the
rancher found. So, that's where we're
headed. I'm going to get moving.
Oh.
From an aerial view
this whole landscape seems pretty
straightforward somewhat easy, but when
you get down in it and start hiking
through it it's a lot more rugged than
it seems.
That sound is the sound of locusts, not
the birds, just that
millions of popping sounds.
What I try to do as I'm going up this
peak, anytime I find a folder or ridge
in the ground, I start following it
uphill with the hopes that maybe
there'll be something built along it.
Since we know that that's where they
tend to build out here.
Oh.
Looks like the base of one of their
towers. I'm going to walk around to the
other side.
I'm really hoping that one of these
towers hasn't fallen, but
just keep coming across ones that have
fallen.
I don't know if they've fallen in the
last 100 years or if they fell a long
time ago.
But staring at all this rock, I can't
help but be impressed by how much effort
it took to haul these rocks in. I mean,
some of them look like they're 2
300-plus pounds.
So, you can imagine how much work it
took to build over two stories tall.
I think what I want to do is fly the
drone up about 25 ft,
a height that the archaeologist said the
towers were.
One of them they claimed was around 33
ft tall.
Let's go up to at least 25 ft and get
its POV.
So, from this tower's point of view, you
could see the site where we started.
And we're going to head up
to the top of this ridge.
See if there's anything up there.
Then we're going to follow it all the
way down to the end of it to where I
think is the site that the rancher
found.
They're not building temples out here.
They're building towers for protection.
How do we know that they built them for
protection?
Well, that ties in to what happened out
here.
And I promise I'll get into it, but I
still want to keep exploring. So, let's
move up to the top of the ridge.
We've entered the next phase. The real
annoying phase
of the locust.
Oh.
That's natural, right?
There's no way they fit those
together like that.
This is the same rock. Maybe just
cracked under pressure.
To fit this contour here.
That's something you see way down south,
like the Olmecs in Latin America.
These are probably placed by hand.
These seem placed by human hands, but
this one just seems
really incredible.
Maybe this was a natural wall here that
they added to.
It's kind of in a square.
That wall looked so perfect and then as
I got closer, it seemed to be natural.
And at the same time
it seemed stacked.
I mean, look at this one though.
No, that's not natural.
I don't exactly know what to make of
that. Um
it's unusual.
Seems part man-made and part natural.
I'm going to head up hill to the top.
Come on, Max.
Oh.
All right, this is
clearly
something.
Looks like the base of another tower.
Unfortunately, not standing 25-30 ft
tall, but still looks like the base of a
tower.
This is pretty impressive. This is
12 ft tall. I know it's not a lot to
look at, but the fact that there's still
12 ft of height out of this and uh
this is just the base of it. I could
only imagine how high it went. Maybe
this is one of those 30 plus foot
towers.
>> [sighs]
>> Almost to the top. Probably got
another 3 or 400 ft, but
I'm noticing
it rises up into a very sharp point.
Oh, this kind of looks
Oh, yeah. This looks like the base of
a structure.
Ah, I don't think we're ever going to
find a tower.
Oh, yeah.
The base of another one.
Here's the view from the opposite side.
>> I didn't notice that little bit of wall
until I saw it in the drone, so I want
to go check it out.
Oh, cool. Finally get to see some of the
structure as it was.
Oh, wow.
Look at that.
That's burnt corn cob.
I wonder what it's doing here on the
surface. It's a fresh recently. Oh, wow,
look.
It's a burnt piece of wood there.
See the tree rings.
Oh my gosh. Look.
Holy cow, look at
Wow, I've never seen actual corn kernels
on the cob and then to have them burnt.
I don't know if you know what that means
to find burnt corn kernels.
Now, a drought had set in here and
people were resource guarding and
attacking each other. If you're burning
whole kernel corn,
you're not really taking their
resources.
Now, there are stories that these people
were practicing dark medicine, dark
magic.
Some of the first tales of witchcraft
were out here.
And so, was it their neighbors that came
in and wiped them out?
Is that why they burned these places?
As a way to kill or cleanse whatever bad
spirit was there?
Is that why the corn was burned as well?
You didn't burn your own food.
Your enemy burned your food,
killed you, set your home on fire,
burned all your resources.
>> [snorts]
>> I was hoping
to find some more structures along this
lower ridge, but not seeing any.
Almost to the top.
So, I made it to the top, and so far I'm
not seeing any remnants of any
structures up here.
But, uh
we got miles along this ridge
before we get to where I think
the site that the rancher found is.
You want some water, Max?
You need some more, Max?
Yeah.
I don't think I'm going to make it
today. The sun's about to set and uh I'm
pretty wiped. Think I'm going to sleep
out tonight, not set up my tent.
And uh
I don't think it's going to rain, so
let's cross our fingers.
Wow, what a view.
Came over the ridge just to get a view
of the sunset and
that's incredible. I caught it just as
the sun was setting.
I think that's a good way to end the
day.
I'm going to keep my camp simple and
make some dinner
and call it a night.
I'll see you in the morning.
Good morning. It's not the greatest view
this morning, but uh
pretty peaceful.
>> All right, so I'm in the vicinity of the
site that I think the rancher found.
Uh, this site is said to be north of
these peaks here.
At the edge of
the mesa that I'm standing on. So, I
think what I'm going to do is look
around on foot and if it becomes a
really hard, then we'll try and find it
with the drone.
From ground level, it's just over my
head, so maybe 6 and 1/2 ft.
>> In the archaeological reports that I've
read,
it says that they're still standing
anywhere from 25 to 37 ft tall. And
where I'm standing on this downhill
side, you could see all this rubble.
All the way to the top is over 30 ft, so
is that what they meant?
So, I don't know if the report from the
'30s was a little misleading or if these
have crumbled in the last 100 years.
I think that's another layer of the
mystery.
Oh, from here
you could see
that's another base of a tower.
I was thinking about these being used as
signal towers.
There was probably different things to
communicate, but the obvious reason to
build them
is to warn each other. So, what if the
enemy killed them first and they were no
longer able to light a signal fire?
Well, if they burn the structure,
that's quite a large signal fire. I
imagine all these towers lit up warning
everyone the enemies were in the
neighborhood.
How long did they live in fear out here
after the first tower got attacked?
Was it a few days?
Was it weeks? Was it a year or years?
Wow.
This mountain's pretty significant. I
know there aren't any walls there, which
you know,
is unfortunate, but
this thing is still
really tall.
You could see it that big tower that we
saw earlier this morning.
Now, what the rancher found is really
heavy. He said that he had found bones
spilling out of these ruins.
Now, the first tower that they found
showed signs that it had burned. So, if
these towers are 25 to 35 ft tall, could
imagine that inside there was levels.
Some of the upper levels had burned
and collapsed, part of the top tower
collapsing through the lower floors.
And inside that tower
were a lot of bodies.
They found a body with arrows in it.
And those arrows were partly burned.
One man had a blow to his forehead, his
skull bashed with a hole in it.
Maybe from an axe or a club.
Now, they described that the charred
process actually preserved some of the
bodies. There was still facial
expressions on one of the men.
So, it wasn't just bones that they found
some 800 years later.
They found one woman clutching a bow in
one hand and an arrow in another.
Seems like she was ready to defend
herself or was probably in the process
of defending herself.
There was a young man, they thought
maybe 17, who tried to crawl in the
ventilator shaft. They found his head
and his shoulders partway in the
ventilator shaft.
And so, they're assuming that maybe he
was trying to get air.
But,
he also had arrows in his back.
So, was he shot first and tried to crawl
in there, or was he trying to get air
and then the arrows rained down from
above?
Those details are lost.
Only the people who know are gone.
There was a girl
with strips of buckskin in the strands
of her hair.
And I think about the life that she
lived out here before she was killed.
We all know someone like her,
an innocent teenage girl.
Maybe she's saying, "Hi."
When did she die? Did she watch her
loved ones, her family members die
around her?
Was she the last one killed?
Did she watch her brother try and crawl
in a ventilator shaft to get air?
Was that her mother clutching her bow in
one hand and arrow in the other?
Had she managed to get a few shots off
and hit her enemy?
It's unfortunate the last emotions that
she felt
were pain.
The lives that they led out here, there
must have been laughter and joy and
heartache.
And they were just trying to survive out
here.
And then someone
ended all that.
When the first tower was burned, I'm
sure all the neighboring towers saw it.
And fear must have been struck
throughout the land as the signal went
from mountain range from ridgeline to
ridgeline all the way back
to that one that we started at
at the beginning of this trip.
Let's go back to that one and I'll tell
you what happened there.
>> [music]
>> So, the archaeologist that excavated one
of the pit houses out here, he first
came across a body
missing its legs.
Inside that pit house, it turned out
there was a pile of bodies. There was 10
total.
They found a woman with an arrow in the
back of her skull,
one in her forehead. They found a body
with an arrow through the rib cage. They
found another body with an arrow lodged
in the sacrum, which is the area between
your hip bones. The arrow point on that
one was a shark's tooth.
Which in a way is fascinating and cool,
but not if you're the recipient of that
arrow.
And the list goes on and on, but
one thing interesting about all the
bodies is
they didn't have feet or hands. They'd
been severed off and they were gone.
They were missing.
Now, there are stories that these people
were practicing dark magic.
Some of the first tales of witchcraft
were out here.
And so, was it their neighbors that came
in and wiped them out?
But if it was purely as a cleansing
mechanism to wipe out a wicked people,
why did they take their hands and their
feet? Why did they cut them off?
Is it just merely proof that they wiped
them out, or were they taken as a
trophy?
They're taken as a trophy.
It seems that they were just eliminating
them.
One thing that I take away from this is
the value that these places hold. I
think that's partly why I do these
series. I pass by so many places that
have stories that we don't know about.
But if you dig a little deeper,
you'll find a human connection.
Something that gives context to the
land. Often times, something that gets
forgotten.
Thank you for joining me on this one.
I'll see you on the next one.